[Music]
for
e
SC
know
the table and I'm glad you're here I'm
glad here and also a big welcome to
those joining us online and I know
sometimes it can take courage to walk
into a church building um
and even if you've been coming here for
a while sometimes it can take take
something to get up and get yourself
moving and come to church especially on
a Sunday evening so good job good job I
hope the service blesses you and I hope
you feel very welcome here um I have a
couple of uh announcements before we get
going tonight um and by the way you guys
picked a great night to be here we have
none other than Megan grey Herring
giving the message tonight and yeah yeah
so um she's wonderful she's a great
speaker and I know you guys are really
going to enjoy her so uh besides that as
far as announcements go we have our
welcome to the table class coming up on
uh Sunday December 10th that will happen
before the service uh what is welcome to
the table well if you're new here or
want to just learn more about our
community and what we're about and where
we're going where we came from the
Welcome to the table class is for you uh
it is Sunday December 10th before the
service starts at 33 3:30 and then uh
you can just stay and uh come to service
afterwards if you would like to be a
part of that you can register via the QR
code that will be up on the screens just
take your your phone snap a picture of
it and uh click on the link that'll take
you to the RSVP sign up form for that
there is Child Care available if you
need that and then secondly we have
baptisms coming up at the beginning of
the year in January so if you were
interested in baptism if you would like
more information about baptism what is
it why is it important in the Christian
faith you'll want to go to one of our
two baptism classes that are happening
December 10th and December 17th right
after the service okay you can also RSVP
with the QR code let us know you're
coming to that
those are classes that Brett will lead
and uh tell you all about baptism there
uh and then lastly Christmas is coming
up quickly um I mean Christmas is what
next week no not Christmas
December my brain uh December December
is next week which means Christmas is is
coming quickly uh on Christmas Eve which
happens to be on a Sunday this year
Sunday December 24th we will be having
Christmas Eve services right here uh at
400 p.m. so please note the time change
if you get here at 5: you're going to
miss it so 4M Christmas Eve friends
family anybody you'd like to invite of
course they're welcome to come so we
hope you'll join us for that all right
how about before we get into worship and
the message we take some time just to
quiet ourselves quiet the chatter set
aside the day set aside the week
ahead so if you're comfortable doing so
you can close your
eyes can take a deep breath
in
exhale should embrace some
silence and be here
now
God thank you for
tonight thank you for our
community God thank you for this being a
safe and stable place to come every
Sunday night I'm so grateful for it and
I thank you for all of our
volunteers and for those who make the
service
possible and for Pleasant Valley who
makes this space available for us every
week so God help us to um open our
hearts and our minds tonight for
whatever you have for
us and I pray that we would feel your
presence that we would feel your peace
especially as we embark on the holiday
season which isn't always a wonderful
time of year for everyone so God may we
bring all of who we are all that we have
going on and just lay it at your feet
feet and exchange it for your peace and
your love that is always there for
us and we thank you God for that in
Jesus name
amen amen thanks
Karen would you guys go ahead and stand
with us we are going to open with
worship like Karen said and um I know
for many of us we've come from different
backgrounds different Church traditions
and different ways of worshiping and I
know a number of us who sort of have at
different times walked away from their
traditional experience of worship for
one reason or another and it can be hard
sometimes to come back and re-engage
that space and know how to re-engage it
so I read something that was I just
thought insightful and helpful earlier
um it's by an artist that I followed for
a number of years who's had a very
interesting like path in faith and um
has recently kind of come back to it um
it's by Michael gunger and this is what
he had to say he said through all of it
here's what I've discovered I really
love God and I missed the good parts of
worshiping with other people and when I
say worship I'm not talking about the
Shamy homage paying to some other being
somewhere else but the experience of
love and connection that can happen when
people get together and sing to their
source for me the truest worship is
simply and fully loving what is worship
is allowing every breath sensation and
experience of life to become a sensuous
embodied Hallelujah worship is saying
yes to your life and to your
source so if that is a helpful framework
as we enter in to worship tonight let's
just um let's try to be in a posture of
saying yes to the life that's in front
of us and to to the one who gives us
life to our source Josh is going to get
us started tonight on the way so you
guys join him and sing along where you
can through every
battle through every heart break through
every
circumstance that I believe that you are
my
Fortress you are my
portion you are my Hiding
Place I believe you are the
way the
truth the
light I believe you are the
way the
truth the
light
I believe through every
blessing through every
promise through every breath I
take I believe that you are
provider you are
protector you are the one I
love I believe you are the way
the
truth the
light die believe you are the
way the
truth the
life I believe you
are
it's a New
Horizon and I'm set on
you to meet me here today mercies that
are
new all my fears and
doubts they can all come true because
they can't stay long when I'm here with
you
it's a New
Horizon and I've said on
you you meet me here today mercies that
are
new all my fears and
doubts they can all come
to because they can't stay
long you are the
way the truth
Tru the
life I believe you are the
way the
truth the
light I believe you
are it's a New
Horizon and I'm set on
you to meet me here today
mercies that are
new all my fears and
doubts they can all come
to because they can't stay long and I
believe you are the
way the
truth the
light and I believe you are the way
the
[Music]
truth the
life I believe you
are all right we want to dismiss the
kids to their classrooms so if you guys
can go gently into those rooms second
through sixth is over here and first
grade and down is over here in this
classroom thank you Angie Maggie Kelly
all of our other kids ministry workers
[Music]
elbel and now let's enter into the
prayers of the people if you guys would
read this aloud with me and um then
we'll leave space for each of you to
offer up something that you may be
carrying into this space tonight a name
numerous situation we'll just speak
those aloud in that space and then we'll
finish out the prayer
together for the city of saxi Texas and
for every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you for the Good
Earth you have given us and the wisdom
and the will to conserve it we pray to
you for the old and the sick for the
Widow and orphan
for the injured and suffering we pray to
you for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them we pray to you for the
vulnerable the marginalized and those
unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you
for those experiencing loss loneliness
and disconnection and for those
struggling with mental and emotional
health we pray to
you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to
[Music]
you
for the names and moments that we have
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts we pray to you that
they may have life and light he heing
and hope peace and a deep sense of your
presence
[Music]
amen the empty F the wounded heal the
broken back together the poor are
blessed the weary rest we will Dance
[Music]
Forever the blinded SE the chained are
free the doubtful now
believer the outcast known the orphan
home
You Are My
Redeemer
behold
behold behold What Love Can Do
heing all
[Music]
new the Lost return The Voice
theing the sh the world away creation
all
composing the sad and true the Earth
reew found it
singer
dark You Are My
Redeemer
behold
behold behold What Love Can Do
behold he's making all things new
behold
behold behold
love
behold
behold he's making all things
new
[Music]
we' been Str down we're not
destroyed we' sown in
tears will reap and joy reap struck down
we're not
destroyed we've sown in
tears will reap and
joy My Eyes Are
Open My Eyes
Are
behold
behold behold love can do
behold he's making all things new
behold
behold behold What Love Can Do
behold he's making all things
new
he's making all
[Music]
new this next song um talks about uh
trusting that God is a faithful father
and um I just wanted to state that the
the word father right there um I would
love it if we could look at it Through
The Eyes of
just
love and receiving love from someone who
is a safe
space like Karen was talking about
earlier being in the midst of a love
where you don't have to be
afraid where it's not about your
performance or what you've
done it's not about measuring
up so whether that's maybe a love that
you've received from your father or
maybe from a mother or some other person
in your life who's shown you
unconditional safety and
space let's sing this song to our source
who is our safe space who has loved us
unconditionally
[Music]
tear
downall bu up every W buil up every wall
buil up CU you deserve every in my heart
every of my heart every of my
heart come and Tear Down the Walls I've
buil up every wall
buil every wall
buil you
deserve of my heart every of my heart
every of my heart
Andy I am trusting that you are a
faithful father all that you have it is
good
aous with love like no other you come
and break through to me over and over
and over again I am bringing my heart to
you with open
hands closer and closer you're drawing
me as the deps of my heart lay before
you again
[Music]
tear down W of build every W of build
every W of
build and you deserve every piece of my
heart every piece of my my heart every
of my
heart I am that you are a faithful
father and all that you have it is
good cuz you're a generous G with love
like no other won't you come and breakr
to me over and over and over
again I am bring my heart to you with
open hands cler and closer you're
drawing me in as the dance of my heart
lay before you again and over and over
and over again I am bringing my heart to
you with open
hands closer and closer you dra me in as
the dep of my heart lay you
[Music]
again
so
deserve
just sing
come come Tear Down the Walls I've buil
up every wall I've buil every wall I've
buil cuz you deserve every of my heart
every of my heart every of
[Music]
my you deserve it
all I can trust you
[Music]
guys God where there are walls that
we've built up where there is distance
between
us where we've compartmentalized you
into Sunday evenings
or bedtime prayers
or different spaces God tonight we want
to open up our hearts to invite you into
every piece of our
life we don't want to run
away from the pain or the reality God
but we want to be present to what you're
doing in our hearts
tonight this
week right
now we want to trust God that you're
doing a good work and that your work
always leads to more love always leads
to more freedom always leads to more
grace and
forgiveness you are a good
God
so would we keep opening up our hearts
to you and letting you
do your thing in our lives and in this
community in this
city in our
worlds in Jesus name
amen all right would you guys turn to
the people around you and make them feel
welcomed and at home and then will come
and share the message with
us um what I'm about to admit my husband
I told my husb uh said no one as a
teenag opinion you are an old
woman but if you had asked me in high
school what my favorite movie was I
would have quickly responded with gig
gig was a
1959 film starring Sandra d and it told
the story of a 17-year-old Francine
Lawrence AKA G who rejected all of her
friends pressur to spin their summer man
hunting note not everything quite ages
well uh she also pushed back against her
parents who continually tried to set her
up with a family son of a family friend
um Jeffrey Matthews yuck instead her
calling was for the ultimate to spend
her summer with a bunch of beach bombs
Moon doggy and the Big Kahuna learning
to shoot the curl surf they made it look
so easy right it was was pictures of
legit Surfers from afar spliced together
with uh the actors on stationary
surfboards on a green screen like this
it it made surfing look like the thing
right so when my mother said hey we're
going on a you know trip to Hawaii what
would you like to do immediately out of
my mouth surf I want to surf so she
kindly arranged for us my brother and I
to have a surf lesson we arrive and the
surf instructor teaches us to how to hop
on our boards uh we're to watch out for
the coral and created this system of
like move paddling out sliding over
riding down the wave and then getting
out of the way of the people in front
who were behind you right seemed easy
you know images of gigg filled my mind I
was already hoping for my own Moon doggy
like this was going to be gold
only my experience consisted of me
running into another surf student
sending her home with a broken rib
flashing my instructor when my top got
stuck to the board as I'm getting out of
the water and completely destroying my
feet on the coral this was not the gig
experience I had dreamed
of so in a totally cheesy transition did
you know that the Bible tells a story of
someone else who tried to stay on top of
the water yes today we're going to be
looking at the story of where Peter
walked on the water to Jesus uh and
we're going to be looking at through the
account in Matthew but before we turn
there let's set the stage Jesus has just
found out that John the Baptist has died
and he really wants to get away and have
some space to pray only 5,000 men plus
women plus children all follow him and
of course out of compassion he begins
heing healing them and he spends his day
[Music]
serving gets to dinner time and oh there
everybody's hungry what are we going to
do so he pulls the miracle of the
feeding uh of the whole group with five
loaves of bread and two
fish then he's done he's he dismisses
everybody he says uh crowd you go home
disciples get in the boat and head on
and he takes some time to
pray and so that's where we be again in
Matthew
14:22 immediately Jesus made the
disciples get into the boat and go on
ahead of him to the other side while he
dismissed the crowd after he had
dismissed them he went up on the
mountain side by himself to pray later
that night he was there alone and the
boat was already a considerable distance
from L buffeted by the waves because the
wind was against it shortly before Dawn
Jesus went out to them walking on the
lake when the disciples saw him walking
walking on the lake they were terrified
it's a ghost they said and cried out in
fear immediately Jesus said to them take
courage it is I do not be afraid Lord if
it is you Peter replied tell me to come
to you on the water come he said then
Peter got down out of the boat walked on
the water and came toward Jesus but when
he saw that the wind he was afraid and
beginning to sink cried outl save me
immediately Jesus reached out his hand
and caught him you of little faith he
saidh do you doubt and when they climbed
into the boat the wind died down and
those who were in The Boat worshiped him
saying truly you are the Son of God all
right so let's break down this story
first we have an exhausted Jesus he just
wants some time alone right he's in
grief he has spent this day serving he
just wants space to pray to rest to
grieve to be
alone and what I love about this scene
is that Jesus insist upon setting
boundaries to take that space right um
prior to being married to my husband
Christian I lived at a very unhealthy
Pace I believed in yes right fill that
pled up with everything I can until my
body finally said enough I'd catch a
cold and it would lay me out to force me
to pause right
but here Jesus models for us this
ability to say enough to take the space
for self-care and and to know what he
needs so after he does that after he has
taken that time to pray to grieve to
have time alone he needs to catch up
with the disciples right so this is that
like Pythagorean theorem right
hypothenuse is you know shorter than the
edges or whatever the geometry thing is
right he's going to the disciples in the
fastest way I guess through the water I
think I guess that makes sense and so he
does he walks on the water to them and
the disciples they logically think it's
a ghost because they've never seen a
human walking on water before uh Jesus I
disen ifies himself Peter of course like
any human says let me get out to you
well if I'm really going to look at this
the first time it takes me to a really
snarky Place either one Peter has sucked
up that gig lie that walking on water is
easy or maybe Peter is like Olaf right
little dim Olaf's dreaming of summer
because he's a snowman not realizing
that snow melts in Sun so Peter's not
realizing that walking on water doesn't
work for him I don't know but let's
refrain Peter knows what kind of day
Jesus has had and he is willing to risk
the wind the water the scary to get out
out of the security of the boat to go be
with Jesus in the water to be honest
that's kind of empathetic that's really
Brave and that takes a lot of guts to go
when he's seen someone who has had a
really crappy day to go be with them to
be present in that
pain so I kind of give one to Peter on
that and so Peter though like takes hold
of what has happened
physics or whatever has sned in and he
starts
sinking Peter and uh and Jesus says this
statement about Peter not having faith
so the question is is is Peter not
having faith in himself or is Peter not
having faith in
Jesus to be quite honest it doesn't
matter for the sake of this sermon right
because both are very true realities of
the human life so if we're going to say
it's him not having faith in Jesus Jesus
this whole concept of doubt and
deconstruction and like we're all very
familiar with that right and there are
thankfully lots of good authors Peter NS
Brian Mclaren Barbara Brown Taylor
Rachel Evans who are writing good works
addressing that struggle with faith in
God so for example Peter N says doubt
can do things spiritually that nothing
else can do sometimes we think of our
faith as a castle safe comfortable
familiar but what if God doesn't want us
to be comfortable and safe what if
comfortable and safe keep God at a
distance doubt tears down the castle
walls to force us on a journey and
Barbara Brown Taylor picks him up right
where he ends she says I think faith
means Walking with God in the dark we
don't see an end to the journey but we
trust God's promise that the destination
is
good and so this doubt in God is very
common secondly it's very common for us
to lose faith in ourselves our anxiety
Creeps in those images of negative selft
talk the the doubt that we can do hard
things begins to surface and us
and keep us from even trying because
we're too scared of
failing sometimes that begins to affect
our mental health to the point we even
need to get see a professional to help
us work through that those doubts are
very common and so regardless of what
Peter is doubting in I get it I kind of
feel sorry I I get what he's
feeling with this point Peter's starting
to sink and Jesus reaches out his hand
and they get back to the safety of the
boat I think this is one of the most
beautiful pictures of what it means to
be the
church having this awareness of that of
someone else's pain not being so
self-absorbed that I can't even tell
that someone else is hurting to being
willing to get out of the boat to go be
with that person in pain it doesn't mean
that I'm fixing the problem but it means
being present with them three
acknowledging when I'm in over my head
and being able to ask and tell someone
else what's going on um vocalizing what
I'm afraid of for giving out your hand
to the one who's feeling overwhelmed
that they so overwhelmed that they might
drown and being willing to accept a hand
when I'm the one feeling like I'm
drowning last year was a really bad year
I was going through a toxic work
situation and every week I would come to
my meetup group and share what was going
on and sometimes I felt like Jesus very
consumed by grief and exhaustion and
they were there to come out to be with
me to be present in the pain that I was
going through sometimes I felt like
Peter so overwhelmed that I was drowning
in this negative emotion and they were
there to extend a hand to pull me
out that sort
of
experience doesn't just stay in the them
helping me it's a reciprocal thing right
I get the privilege of doing that for
others in the community I get to be able
to be present when my Meetup Group
people are also hurting but it's not all
Gloom there's also the celebration of
success and the good things that are
happening in our group there's the
awareness of where God is present in
those ups and downs in life pointing out
that the Divine is with us regardless of
our
circumstances and so that sort of
communal experience can happen into a
lot of settings and that is
great but we're here at the table and so
we're talking about meetups and meetups
are a really awesome opportunity for you
to have that sort of Peter Paul I'm
sorry uh Jesus and Peter sort of
relationship um where you share with the
ups and the downs and you can extend the
hand and accept a hand and so if all you
don't do is come on a Sunday and listen
to a sermon that's great this is
wonderful but you're going to be missing
out and so I would like to encourage you
if you're not a part of a Meetup do
please consider to join one I'll be back
outside at the end of the service and
you can chat with me or there's this
awesome Q QR code where you can sign up
to join uh one of our meetup groups I'd
love to talk to you about it um but I do
want to acknowledge that for some people
Church small groups is a sore spot right
they've had a negative experience with
one and so that might range from church
hurt all the way to deep spiritual
trauma and so if that is you I am sorry
that you had that sort of experience um
I can't fix it but I'd love to hear your
story or breath or any of the leaders
would love to talk to you more um about
that so I would love for you all to join
our community as we learn to serve
through life together and one way that
we get to be Community is through
practicing communion and so I would like
to invite you all to practice partake in
communion with us tonight um here at the
table we practice an open table so if
means if anybody is wanting to partake
you may partake um we also have on the
bread is gluten-free the red is wine and
the clearish color is the grape
juice um and the way we do it is we go
row by row creating a line in the center
once you get your elements you're more
than welcome to take them as you wish
right then or if you want to sit and
take a moment that's fine too no one up
here is going to be leading you through
communion so with
that this is the table not of the church
but of the Lord it is is made ready for
those who love him and for those who
want to love him more so come you who
have much faith and you who have little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long you have tried
to follow and you who have failed come
because it is the Lord who invites you
it is his will that those who want him
should meet him here so come to the
table
[Music]
we wanted to close out the service today
with the song called find the light by
David Ramirez and what I love about this
song is it's uh it's like a blessing
it's almost like its own benediction um
but in the in the spirit of community
and leaning on each other um I love when
people in this room have just spoken
life to me just a word of encouragement
something to hang on to some hope that I
needed and I hope that this song is that
for you guys today as you go out and um
just remember as we've kind of ended
this season of like Thanksgiving sort of
you know it's coming to an end and we're
getting going in the busyness of the
next season I hope that we can pause and
remember to Speak Life remember to lift
each other up and to lean on each other
just like Megan was talking about
tonight so if you guys want to stand and
sing this with us you're welcome to or
you can sit back and enjoy um it's
totally up to
[Music]
you wish upon on you
peace I wish upon you
Grace I Wish For Less of what you want
and more of what you
need I wish upon you in all life with a
heart that stays
young but most of all I wish upon you
love I Wish Upon Your Truth
and all you feel is
doubt I hope you know that an open mind
know when shut
out you a brave that will always rise
above but most of all I wish upon you
love and as the sun sets and the Moon
Moon begins to
rise so even in the darkness you find
the
light you'll find the
[Music]
light even in the darkness you find
I wish upon you an easy I wish upon you
hard times I hope you know that both Joy
and
Pain
moments
[Music]
are
that of all I wish upon you love
so as the sun sets and the moon begins
to
rise so even in the darkness you'll find
the
light you'll find the
[Music]
light
you'll find the
light so even in the
darkness you'll find the
[Music]
light
try this one hey
worked thank you so much for being with
us tonight I hope that the service
blessed you and reminded you that you're
not
alone um don't for forget about our
welcome to the table class coming up and
the baptism classes coming up if you
missed those announcements at the
beginning don't worry just scan the QR
code uh you can also go to our website
the tabl tx.org and get information
there as well uh or you can ask me uh or
any of other of our other leaders we'd
be happy to talk with you um if you
would like prayer a hug someone to talk
to information about our meetups come
find me after the service you can also
find Megan by the way thank you Megan
that was wonderful I so enjoyed that and
it felt like such a timely message too
as we head into the end of the year and
the beginning of next year what a time
to intentionally surround yourself with
good solid Community people that you can
be yourself with that others can be
themselves with you um be brave and take
that step if you don't have a Meetup
group or a community where you can feel
like you can be full of yourself um it
will be a gift to yourself I promise um
also those of you who are new here and
uh those of you who are watching online
who are new uh please don't leave
without filling out our visitor card you
can do that with the QR code we also
have uh cards out on the little itty
bitty table in the lobby um fill that
out uh either online or out here in the
lobby and uh we would love to thank you
for being here with us tonight and
follow up with you with more information
and answer any questions that you might
have um also communities like this uh
unfortunately are rare ones that are
truly inclusive and welcoming um and we
want to keep doing this as long as we
can so if you resonate with our mission
and our values you can give online again
using the QR code uh as well as the
little uh wooden box in the lobby um
lastly I would really really love to
send you out with a benediction so if
you're comfortable doing so you can rise
to your
feet and just take a posture in any way
for you that is receiving some people
like to put their hands out like this
some people like to close their eyes so
they can really listen and absorb the
words or just
open your heart these are words that are
written for this community so if you are
hearing my voice these words are for you
specifically so I hope you will take
them that
way you are a child of
God you are a child of
God this is true on your best day and
it's true on your worst
day so as you go into your week ahead
with its yet to be be determined highs
and lows and everything in
between go with the assurance that you
are loved you are worthy and you are
accepted just as you
are and go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend these same
Gifts of compassion and Grace and love
to everyone you come in contact with
have a great week be blessed and we hope
to see you back here next Sunday good
night you find
the you'll find the
light who you'll find
Al who you find
Al
who you'll find
the you'll find the
[Music]
light you'll find the
light yes even in the
Darkness you'll find the
light